we know what the universe looks like
today and we have a pretty good idea how
it started with the Big Bang but what
happened in the 14 billion years between
the Big Bang and now how did galaxies
like our Milky Way evolve to test our
theories scientists at MIT have built a
computer model of the universe a
simulation so complex that calculating
it on a single desktop would take 2,000
years they modeled a volume of space
almost 350 million light-years across a
large enough chunk to be representative
of the whole universe but detailed
enough to delve into individual galaxies
a feat no other team has managed the
model doesn't just tackle the universe's
huge range of scales
it also richly describes the forces at
work much better than previous attempts
by factoring in the laws of physics and
a variety of theories about how gas is
cool stars evolve and black holes grow
the model recreates both the galaxies
and stars we can see and the dark matter
and dark energy that we can't
the simulation starts just 12 million
years after the Big Bang when things
start to get interesting
Dark Matter clusters together under the
force of gravity if we could see it it
would look like a web in fact scientists
call it the cosmic web where dark matter
is densest shown as bright pink spots
ordinary matter also clumps and forms
into galaxies now we're looking at the
ordinary matter blue shows relatively
cold clouds of gas where stars form
Green is warmer gas while red and white
show hot regions around the most violent
galaxy's supermassive black holes grow
at the center of these as they gobble up
matter they superheat the material
around it blowing out gas in these
violent white bursts over time this
enriches the space between galaxies with
warmth but sparse gas
the simulation also shows the
distribution of different elements the
early universe was full of helium and
hydrogen as stars evolve and die in
supernovae they fuse these basic
chemicals into heavier elements such as
carbon and oxygen as well as metals the
violent bursts around black holes spread
these elements across space the pink
clouds you see here life depends on
these chemical building blocks only when
you have enough of them two planets and
complex molecules form we're looking at
dark matter again and we've almost
reached the present day fourteen billion
years of the universe's evolution has
pulled a tightly woven Dark Matter web
into a looser network of giant galaxy
clusters a big challenge the team say
was recreating the variety of galaxies
we observe the models forty thousand
galaxies include this spiral one like
our Milky Way in fact the simulation
produces a world that's remarkably
similar to the real universe as we see
it through our telescopes and because
the simulation matches our observations
so well it gives us greater confidence
in our understanding of the universe
how it began how galaxies formed what
it's made of and the laws that govern it
of course the model is not perfect but
where it fails the simulation challenges
our view of the universe it begs the
question if our descriptions don't match
what we see what might we yet be missing
you